space launch complex 40 at cape
canaveral space force station
my name is andy tran i'm a quality
engineer here at spacex joining you from
our headquarters in hawthorne california
thank you for tuning in for our 18th
launch of starlink this year and
spacex's 27th mission of 2021. starlink
is a satellite internet constellation
designed and manufactured by spacex that
can provide high-speed low-latency
internet to people living in remote and
rural locations around the globe today's
launch will be our fourth rideshare
mission of the year this launch will be
a longer one as we are reverting to a
circular orbital insertion which
requires two burns of the merlin vacuum
engine on the second stage we are doing
this as it is a mission requirement for
our rideshare customer flying on board
tonight
inside the fairing at the top of the
rocket there are 48 starling satellites
and two black sky satellites black sky
is a global monitoring company that
combines space assets with advanced ai
and machine learning analysis to provide
customers a first to know advantage i'll
share a few more details about these
payloads a bit later in the webcast
as for the 48 starling satellites they
will be inserted into low earth orbit
and bring us one step closer to near
global coverage of the populated world
in 2021.
the latest weather forecast shows about
90 favorable chance of liftoff today the
vehicle the satellites and range are all
looking good to support an on-time
liftoff just over 11 minutes from now
let's take a closer look at the rocket
that you see on screen
falcon 9 our two-stage launch vehicle
stands about 70 meters tall and when
it's fully fueled it'll hold just over
one million pounds of propellant that
the vehicle will burn through in less
than three minutes after liftoff we prep
falcon 9 for launch in our hangar at the
base of the pad upon completing final
checkouts falcon 9 rolled out to the pad
with the starlink and black sky payloads
and went vertical on monday around 5 pm
eastern time from there we had
successful static fire of our nine
merlin 1d engines on the first stage
yesterday
the bottom two thirds of the vehicle is
what we refer to as the first stage you
may be able to see the sit markings left
over from this boosters previous eight
flights supporting the gps three three
mission turks at 5a transporter 2 and 5
previous starlink missions
the first stage accelerates the vehicle
through the earth's atmosphere into
space with the help of nine merlin
engines at the base of the rocket
following separation from the second
stage we'll be attempting to recover our
first stage for a ninth time on our
drone ship a shortfall of gravitas
staged off the coast of florida in the
atlantic ocean you can see it on screen
right now
if successful it will make the 89th
recovery of a falcon 9 first stage and
96 total first stage landings if you
include our falcon heavy booster
recoveries on top of the first stage is
the black carbon fiber inner stage and
then on top of that is the falcon 9
second stage which has a single
merlin vacuum or mvac engine once the
first and second stages separate at
about two and a half minutes into the
mission the mvac engine will ignite and
carry the starlink satellites and two
black sky satellites to a low earth
orbit around the earth
the stack of satellites is safely
enclosed inside of the 17-foot diameter
payload fairing which you see on screen
right now this protects the payload from
aerothermal loads heating and
contamination during ascent once we
reach the vacuum of space we will
jettison the fairing as the second stage
continue it continues its journey to
orbit
just as we reuse the falcon 9 we recover
and reuse our fairing halves as well the
fairing halves we're using today are
brand new and we're going to be
attempting to recover these halves using
our recovery vessel bob
propellants have been loading on the
vehicle since the t-minus 35-minute mark
falcon 9 is a bi-propellant vehicle
which means it uses two propellants a
fuel and an oxidizer an oxidizer is a
type of chemical that a fuel requires in
order to burn most things here on earth
burn using oxygen which is readily
available in the earth's atmosphere but
in space there is no atmosphere to
provide oxygen or other oxidizers so the
rocket needs to carry up their own in
falcon 9's case it's super chilled
liquid oxygen called lox the liquid
oxygen is chilled well below its boiling
point so that it can become what we call
densified which means it has a much
greater amount of mass per volume and we
can load more of it onto the booster
for fuel we use a refined form of
kerosene known as rp1 in addition to its
propellants falcon9 also needs an
ignition source in order to go and for
that we use the chemical t-tab or
triethyl aluminum and triethylborane
currently fuel is nearly fully loaded on
the first stage and starting to load on
the second stage once all tanks are full
both stages will continue to be topped
off with propellant until about the t
minus two minute mark to keep
temperatures as cold as possible
again weather is looking fantastic for
tonight's liftoff
the vehicle and satellites in the
fairing
they are remaining good as well
we are targeting an on-time liftoff just
under seven and a half minutes from now
and as i mentioned earlier today's
mission marks the fourth official
mission under spacex's small set
rideshare program this year which gives
small satellites flexible access to what
is now the most flown operational rocket
in the united states the falcon 9.
tonight we're flying 48 styling
satellites to make room for two black
sky payloads from our customers space
flight
in an effort to make to help black sky
rapidly expand its growing constellation
of high revisit satellites spaceflight
incorporated is managing the launch of
these two additional black sky high
resolution multi-spectral gen 2
satellites to low earth orbit expanding
black skies network in space and
offering of real-time geospatial
intelligence and monitoring services
black sky combines high-resolution
images captured by its constellation of
microsatellites with its proprietary
artificial intelligence software to
deliver analytics and insights to
industries including transportation
infrastructure land use defense supply
chain management and humanitarian aid
so far this year we've launched over 200
rideshare payloads to orbit this
includes the ones launched on the
transporter 1 mission in january a
previous starlink launch in may and the
transporter 2 mission in june
after this mission our next riger
mission is scheduled to launch at the
beginning of next year and that's going
to be transporter 3 which will be a
dedicated rideshare launch to sun
synchronous orbit
as part of our smallsat rideshare
program we offer three dedicated
rideshare missions to sun synchronous
orbits per year as well as launch
opportunities on our sonic missions with
like what you're seeing here today
so we are about five and a half minutes
from liftoff of our 18th starlink launch
of 2021 and the falcon 9 is progressing
into the final stages of the countdown
next up the truss structure next to the
vehicle known as the transporter erector
we also refer to it as the te it will
begin to start to retract away from the
falcon 9 vehicle in preparation for
retracting the te clamp arms will open
up and then the transport erector will
begin to pull away from the rocket
slightly to its pre-launch position
about two degrees from the vehicle
then at t0 hydraulics pull the tee even
further away from falcon 9 as it lifts
off
the transport erector is also the
structure that provides liquids gases
electrical connections to the second
stage as well as air conditioning to the
payload fairing
and the vehicle is continuing to load
propellant
once we're fully topped off we'll have
over one million pounds of kerosene fuel
and liquid oxygen
on screen right now is a view of the
fairing right beneath the fairing those
are the clamp arms that we are expecting
to open up and here they
go once these clamp arms open up you
should start to see the truss structure
begin to recline away from falcon 9 in
preparation for liftoff
again we are continuing to load
propellant on
both the stages the first and second
stages should finish loading propellant
about a minute apart from one another
the first stage finishing up around the
t minus three minute mark and the second
stage finishing up around the t minus
two minute mark
at t minus 60 seconds falcon 9 will be
in startup
this means that the rockets autonomous
internal flight computers have taken
over the launch countdown
and just inside t minus two seconds we
light the merlin 1d engines and then
we're set for liftoff
the starlink payload and the black sky
payloads inside the fairing continue to
be healthy the falcon 9 team is tracking
no issues at this time
so we're starting to hear some hissing
and popping
this is a venting from our
locks lines as part of the transporter
erector's
job to continue to fill the the vehicle
with propellant
we can also start to see some white
clouds forming around the falcon 9
this will
become more and more prominent as we get
closer to t0 this is just that super
cold liquid oxygen starting to densify
and um
form those clouds that you start to see
when it meets the warmer ambient
air temperatures of florida
so again we have a pretty much perfect
weather in florida for today's liftoff
attempt
this is a rideshare mission carrying 48
starlink satellites as well as two black
sky satellites enclosed
in the fairing that you see on screen
right now
and there goes those pissing and hopping
that is normal and expected
at this stage in the countdown
at this point the propellant has been
fully loaded on the vehicle and we are
just under a minute away
both stages should be beginning to
pressurize for liftoff
so we are 40 seconds away let's listen
in to terminal count as we prepare for
liftoff of the 48 starling satellites
and the two black sky satellites
t-minus 30 seconds and counting
t minus 15 seconds of counting
t minus five
four
three
two
one zero ignition liftoff
right
nominal power in telemetry
so we are about a minute into liftoff
falcon 9 has successfully lifted off
from space launch complex 40 at cape
canaveral
station in just a few seconds here we
are expecting the callout for max q that
is the period where the vehicle
experienced the highest amount of
aerodynamic pressures
max q
and there was the call out
so now that we've gone past the period
of high stresses on the vehicle we have
three events happening in quick
succession in about a minute first we
have uh main engine cutoff also referred
to as miko
then stage separation followed by second
engine start one also known as ses1 main
engine cutoff is where all nine merlin
engines on the first stage will shut
down to slow the vehicle down in
preparation for stage separation during
stage separation the first and second
stage will separate from one another the
first stage will make its way back to
earth for landing while the second stage
continues its journey with our
satellites uh with the third event which
is a second engine start one the single
merlin vacuum engine on the second stage
will then ignite and continue to propel
those starlink satellites and black sky
satellites into orbit
stage separation confirmed
[Applause]
[Music]
so you can see on screen we had
successful main engine cutoff
uh followed by stage separation and on
the right-hand side of the screen that
is the single merlin vacuum engine going
red hot
on the left-hand side of the screen is
the view of our first stage i think
we're getting some views of the of
twilight right now as the sun has just
set uh in the east coast in a few
seconds we are expecting faring deploy
and that will expose the satellites to
the vacuum of space
pairing separation confirmed
we got the audio and video confirmation
on the right-hand side of the screen uh
the fairing halves have deployed we are
going to attempt to recover those uh
using our recovery vessel bob later on
in the mission uh for now the uh mission
is going great again the left-hand side
is a view from the top of our first
stage looking downward
you can see little plumes of gas coming
out that is nitrogen
for our as part of our attitude control
system to help orient the the first
stage booster properly as it makes its
way back to attempt its ninth landing on
our drone ship in the atlantic ocean
uh right-hand side is a view of the
second stage merlin vacuum engine the uh
48 starling satellites and the two black
sky satellites that we had mentioned
earlier on the opposite end of that
engine and so again they are going to be
in this burn for another couple of
minutes
as they continue to make their way to
low earth orbit
so in order to make its way back to the
drone ship the first stage needs to
execute two burns uh the first is an
entry burn where three of the merlin 1d
engines
uh will ignite this helps to slow the
stage down as it reenters the upper
parts of the earth's atmosphere the
second burn is the landing burn this is
a single engine burn and this will bring
the vehicle speed down rapidly in order
to land on our drone ship trajectory
nominal
that first burn the entry burn is
expected to start around t plus six
minutes and 22 seconds and last for
about 20 seconds
for those that are just joining us we
are in the middle of
spacex's 27th mission of 2021
both stages have separated we did have a
successful liftoff from space launch
complex 40.
things are continuing to go well
for tonight's mission
so we are about 20 seconds away from the
beginning of that entry burn on the
first stage uh we do have camera views
right now it is a little dark but as
soon as that entry burn starts we should
see that first stage um
being lit
up as it will slow itself down before
hitting the denser parts of the earth's
atmosphere
stage one enterprise startup
one flight termination system is safe
all right three engines have relit on
the first stage
if you're keeping track of the bottom
left-hand side of the screen there is a
um speedometer of sorts that is tracking
the velocity of the first stage you can
see that we're starting to reduce that
velocity burn if you keep an eye on that
as soon as the first stage hits the
denser parts of the atmosphere will
continue to slow down um its speed
in preparation for the next burn the
landing burn
and that landing burn is uh
expected to happen a few seconds after
the t plus eight minute mark
trajectory nominal
the mvac engine performance on the
second stage continues to go well
a few seconds after we complete the
landing burn
we are expecting to turn off this engine
and enter a coast
phase and as a reminder we will be
reigniting this engine
about 50 minutes from now um
stage one london born
there's the call out
the landing burn has begun
terminal guidance
just a few seconds here we're going to
see if we can land this first stage
booster for the ninth time
stage one landing leg deploy
[Music]
you can hear the cheer and the pause and
there's the visual
this first stage booster has landed nine
times this marks our 89th
overall successful recovery of a
thousand nine first
so what we're waiting on now is
confirmation of second engine cutoff as
well
confirmation of a good orbital insertion
as i was speaking we did get that
confirmation um so the second stage uh
with all of its satellites are entering
a coast phase for about 50 minutes we're
gonna leave you with some space tunes
and we'll be back here at the t-plus
59-minute mark
acquisition of signal newfoundland
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
expected loss of signal bermuda
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
[Music]
expected losing signal newfoundland
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
acquisition
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
expected loss of signal good healing
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you